brothers and sisters and dear friends
the marriage documentary is finally here
seven years in the making and in a few
moments you'll be watching the official
trailer
for myself and my team this is far
greater than just a entertainment video
not just a mere documentary for us it is
we hope that you benefit from this as
much as we benefited making this and for
myself living through it
episode one will be out very soon enjoy
the trailer
were you faithful to her
we couldn't even cause a psychological
abuse I don't know really I was at home
waiting for you yeah yeah I was driven
by a raging Revenge to me it was like I
want to see to me sometimes
I want forgiveness because I made the
whole family we will have to be part of
someone to start
she doesn't
I wasn't a bad person I was never
physical with them
foreign
I hope you guys enjoyed the action film
trailer brothers and sisters but in the
documentary brother and sisters not just
action real stories are to be told and
lessons to be learned but all of this
problem sisters could not have been done
with the permission Allah and my team
who are behind this and our sponsors if
it wasn't for the sponsors brothers and
sisters the amount of money and
resources
the energy that we needed to do this
problem sisters it would have not been
possible I want to thank Islam net may
Allah bless and preserve them and
they're building a Masjid in Norway as
you guys know please use the link in the
description box to donate number two
gift those restaurant who played a
massive role in believing this project a
couple of years ago and supporting it
Sunnah currency who meant gold coins and
silver coins sisters that you can have
as backup subhanallah and many of the
different Services may Allah bless and
preserve them at Penny University who
deal with recruitment for young men who
want to protect and provide for their
families may Allah bless and preserve
every single one of them brothers and
sisters and I want to thank qurani as
well may Allah bless and preserve them
brothers and sisters
and finally brothers and sisters I thank
every single one of you guys for being
patient and I hope you enjoy episode one
because believe me it will be
life-changing
I'll see you guys episode one
assalamualaikum